no shortage of Democrats running for the
White House in 2020 right now there are
18 declared candidates and one more who
plans to make it official this weekend
the Republican incumbent has dismissed
most of them president Trump's 2020
campaign manager Brad parse kale spoke
to Face the Nation moderator Margaret
Brennan about the crowded Democratic
field and the ways they're using social
media what Democrats have impressed you
so far who's mastering the digital game
I don't know I you know do you have the
book full that all the people like IO
turn pages you know none of them right
now I'm not real worried about any of
them right now I think they're gonna
beat up each other so much I am
expecting another 15 I think by the next
weekend it seems like and it's one a day
now I think you know and they better or
or Bernie Sanders they've been given
credit for building out in the digital
space connecting with people that I
still none of them have even touched us
in one metric hit no one's got you
worried you don't think anyone's doing
it well I'm not saying that I'm just
thinking what's got us in a well I mean
we run for it in 2016 but him and
Hillary combined still didn't touch us
mm-hmm so yeah no I'm not worried about
they you know they can think play
catch-up all they want I think the
president has has put a great team and
and and and and God thankfully has
trusted in me and and Jared Kushner and
others too to build a team that you know
is um I think changing the way it's done
and I think look nobody in Republican
politics has ever been close to this
kind of enthusiasm and small-dollar
excitement a lot of a confidence there I
mean why even go to work in the morning
no look though look the key point from
part scale is while Democrats are
raising money in their own stylist for
loan campaigns the president is
consolidating money across the country
and when it comes time to use it
he will have more than enough resources
and that's something that gives a really
campaign a degree of confidence so many
reelection if they were worried do you
think that they would tell Margaret or
anybody else who were worried about and
do you happen to know anybody that they
are worried about but not saying he's
not going to admit it publicly you can
tell that there is a rapid White House
response to Brett or Warrick Bernie
Sanders and Joe Biden that is an
indicator but no the Trump White House
and the Trump campaign is not big on
telegraphing worry well you can catch
more of Margaret Brennan's interview on
Face the Nation that'll be this Sunday
she'll also talk with Democratic
presidential candidate Senator Cory
Booker and Senate Democratic whip dick
Durbin